In the coming weeks and months, we're all going to be hearing so much about Hurricane Katrina, and why the government's response was so abysmal. And already, the blame shifting is like this prize fight that's already in its third or fourth round. Already we've heard officials try to shrug off any attempts at accountability by saying that it's too soon, by saying they're not going to play the blame game. And before the million details and arguments and counterarguments start to make all of our heads woozy, I would just like to repeat here something that was talked about very briefly this week. One of those things that seems so fundamental, that seems to cut through a lot of the supposed debate that's happening and end it definitively.
在接下来的几周和几个月里，我们都会听到很多关于卡特里娜飓风的消息，以及为什么政府的应对措施如此糟糕。目前，推卸责任的行为就像一场已经打到第三或第四回合的拳击比赛。我们已经听到官员们试图通过声称“现在谈还为时过早”或“不想玩指责游戏”来推卸任何问责。在成千上万的细节、争论和反驳让我们头昏脑胀之前，我只想在这里重申本周被简要讨论的一件事。这是一件看起来非常根本的事情，它似乎足以穿透许多所谓的辩论，并彻底终结它。
So much so, that when I would see people on TV posturing and trotting out their talking points, I kept wanting to go back and say no, no, no, no, no, don't forget this thing. It has to do with the biggest argument out there right now, whether the federal government was, in fact, supposed to be in charge of rescuing people and getting food and water and all that into New Orleans, which has come up a lot. Like when the head of Homeland Security, Michael Chertoff, was asked by Tim Russert on Meet The Press, since you knew the storm was coming, why didn't you get buses and trains and planes and trucks in there to evacuate? Chertoff said it wasn't his job.
以至于当我在电视上看到人们摆出姿势、抛出他们的谈话要点时，我一直想回去说：不，不，不，别忘了这件事。这与目前最大的争论有关，即联邦政府是否真的应该负责救援民众，并将食物、水等一切物资运往新奥尔良，这个问题已经被提过很多次了。比如，当国土安全部部长迈克尔·切尔托夫在《会见媒体》节目中被蒂姆·拉瑟特问到，既然你们知道风暴要来，为什么不派公交车、火车、飞机和卡车去疏散民众时？切尔托夫说那不是他的工作。
Tim, the way that emergency operations act under the law is the responsibility and the power, the authority, rests with state and local officials.
蒂姆，在法律框架下，应急行动的运作方式是责任、权力和权威都归属于州和地方官员。
This idea, that it was state and local officials who are the ones who blew it, not the feds, this idea is all over the place, from the talking heads on TV to Rush Limbaugh.
这种认为是州和地方官员搞砸了这一切，而不是联邦政府的观点，到处都是，从电视上的评论员到拉什·林博。
What we had down there was an eminent failure of state and local government. We had incompetence in the mayor's office, incompetence in the governor's office.
我们在那里看到的是州和地方政府的严重失职。我们看到了市长办公室的无能，也看到了州长办公室的无能。
And sure, it is clear, even this early, that there are plenty of things that state and local government did to screw things up. But here's this thing that I read this week, this thing that I kept thinking about all week. It really comes down to a couple of basic facts. The Governor of Louisiana declares a state of emergency the Friday before the storm hits, calls on the federal government to step in. Then President Bush officially declares a state of emergency in Louisiana the next day, Saturday before the storm, and authorizes the Federal Emergency Management Agency to act. You can read the paper where he does this on the White House website. Basically, that should have settled who was in charge.
当然，很明显，即使在这么早的阶段，州和地方政府确实做了很多把事情搞砸的事。但我本周读到的这件事，我整个星期都在思考。归根结底，就是几个基本事实。路易斯安那州州长在风暴来临前的周五宣布进入紧急状态，呼吁联邦政府介入。第二天，也就是风暴来临前的周六，布什总统正式宣布路易斯安那州进入紧急状态，并授权联邦紧急事务管理局采取行动。你可以在白宫网站上读到他签署的文件。基本上，这应该确定了谁负责。
After that happened, there was plenty of authority. There was all the authority in the world.
在那之后，有足够的权力。拥有世界上所有的权力。
We checked out this idea that, from that point the federal government was in fact in charge. We checked that out with several different experts and consultants on these issues this week, and they all agreed that the law is unambiguous. This particular guy is William Nicholson, author of the books Emergency Response, and Emergency Management Law and Homeland Security Law and Policy. And if you're into Homeland Security policy, you might want to check those out.
我们核实了这种观点，即从那时起，联邦政府实际上是负责人。本周，我们就这些问题咨询了几位不同的专家和顾问，他们都一致认为法律是明确的。这位特别的人是威廉·尼科尔森，《应急响应》、《应急管理法》以及《国土安全法与政策》等书的作者。如果你对国土安全政策感兴趣，你可能想去看看这些书。
He says that once the governor asks for help, and the President declares a state of emergency, the feds basically have the broad powers to do what's necessary. And, he says, even if the President hadn't declared a state of emergency, the Head of the Department of Homeland Security, Chertoff, could have acted. There's this whole newfangled way for him to take emergency powers under something called The National Response Plan.
他说，一旦州长请求帮助，总统宣布进入紧急状态，联邦政府基本上就有广泛的权力去做必要的事情。而且他说，即使总统没有宣布紧急状态，国土安全部部长切尔托夫也可以采取行动。根据所谓的《国家应对计划》，他有一种全新的方式来获取紧急权力。
Well, basically the way it works is, the Secretary of Homeland Security designates this as a catastrophic incident, and federal resources deploy to preset federal locations, or staging areas. So they don't even have to have a local or state declaration in order to move forward with this.
嗯，基本上它的工作方式是，国土安全部部长将此指定为灾难性事件，联邦资源会被部署到预设的联邦地点或集结区。因此，他们甚至不需要当地或州的声明就可以推进这一进程。
In other words, it doesn't matter what the governor says, it doesn't matter what the local people say, basically once that happens, they can just go ahead and do what needs to be done to fix the problem?
换句话说，州长说什么不重要，当地人说什么也不重要，基本上只要这件事发生了，他们就可以直接去做需要做的事情来解决问题？
That's correct. It's utterly clear that they had the authority to preposition assets, and to significantly accelerate the federal response.
没错。非常清楚的是，他们有权预先部署资产，并大幅加速联邦的应对。
And they didn't need to wait for the state?
而且他们不需要等州政府？
They did not need to wait for the state.
他们不需要等州政府。
Remember, you heard it here first. Remember you heard it at all. Well, from WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life, distributed by Public Radio International. I'm Ira Glass. Today on our program, we have stories in the aftermath of Hurricane Katrina in New Orleans. One of the things that all of us who work on the radio show thought we could do today during this hour is give people who were in the storm more time than daily news shows could give, to tell their stories and talk about what happened, talk about what they're thinking now.
记住，这是你们第一次在这里听到。记住你们听到了它。从芝加哥WBEZ电台，这是《美国生活》，由国际公共广播电台发行。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天我们的节目中，有关于卡特里娜飓风过后新奥尔良的故事。作为电台节目的工作人员，我们今天在一小时的节目里可以做的一件事，就是给那些经历过风暴的人比新闻节目更多的时间，来讲述他们的故事，谈论发生的事情，谈论他们现在的想法。
We have somebody who was at the convention center, who tells, among other things, the story that her mom wants you to hear, plus one thing she says is being widely misreported and misunderstood in the coverage of the convention center and what happened there. We also have somebody who police prevented from leaving the city. And we have a teenager who explains just what it actually feels like to go without water for two days, and more. Stay with us.
我们有一位曾在会展中心的人，她讲述了她母亲希望你们听到的一些事情，加上她提到的一件事，即在关于会展中心及其发生事件的报道中，被广泛误报和误解的情况。我们还有一位被警察阻止离开城市的人。还有一位十几岁的孩子解释了连续两天没有水到底是什么感觉，等等。请继续收听。
Act one, Middle Of Somewhere. Well, when Denise Moore finally made her way out of New Orleans, she had been at the convention center, she was surprised to see the coverage.
第一幕，身处何方。嗯，当丹妮丝·摩尔最终从新奥尔良出来时，她曾待在会展中心，她对新闻报道感到惊讶。
I kept hearing the word animal, and I didn't see animals. We were trapped like animals, but I saw the greatest humanity I've never seen from the most unlikely places.
我一直听到“动物”这个词，但我没有看到动物。我们像动物一样被困在那里，但我看到了我从未在最不可能的地方见过的最伟大的人性。
Denise Moore eventually ended up at the convention center with her mom, her niece, and her niece's two year old daughter. But the day before the storm, because Denise's mom worked at Memorial Hospital in New Orleans, and because hospital employees are allowed to stay there during hurricanes, all of them went to the hospital. They were given a room to stay in, but later they were kicked out of the room for two white nurses.
丹妮丝·摩尔最终和她的母亲、侄女以及侄女两岁的女儿被困在会展中心。但在风暴发生的前一天，因为丹妮丝的母亲在新奥尔良纪念医院工作，而且医院员工在飓风期间被允许留在那里，他们所有人都去了医院。他们被分配了一个房间，但后来他们被赶出来，把房间腾给了两名白人护士。
Yeah, so I got really mad. So I went home. So I went to the house. I set up my twin bed in the hallway. The hallway, supposedly structurally, is the best place to be if the building is going to be moving around if there's high winds. And good thing I did. Somewhere around 5 o'clock in the morning, I jumped up out of bed. The ceiling started crashing down around me. I was riding that bed like a horse. I was so scared. I had never been that scared for that long. We lived on the second floor, so I was scared it was going to fall through. That even in the hallways, that the building was swaying so much that I'd fall through the floor and end up injured down there, and nobody would find me.
是的，我非常生气。所以我回家了。我回到房子里。我在走廊里搭了我的双人床。走廊通常在结构上是如果建筑物因为强风而晃动时最好的地方。幸好我这样做了。凌晨5点左右，我从床上跳了起来。天花板开始在我周围坍塌。我像骑马一样骑在那张床上。我太害怕了。我从来没有那么长时间地感到那么害怕。我们住在二楼，所以我担心它会掉下去。即使在走廊里，建筑物的晃动也非常剧烈，我怕我会穿过地板掉下去受伤，而没有人会发现我。
Next thing I know, the water is pouring through the ceiling. And people were calling on the phone, you should have stayed at the hospital. It was ridiculous. I was scared fearing for my life for eight full hours. My heart was in my throat. I was like, when this is over, I'm going back to the hospital. And so I went back to the hospital.
接下来我知道的就是水从天花板涌进来。人们在电话里说，你应该留在医院。这太荒谬了。我害怕极了，整整八个小时都在担心我的生命。我的心提到了嗓子眼。我想，这一切结束后，我要回医院。于是我回到了医院。
Can I ask you, before you tell what happens next, why not just evacuate?
在你说接下来发生什么之前，我可以问你，为什么不直接撤离呢？
Well, first of all, my Mom is essential personnel, so she couldn't leave. I don't have a car, so I couldn't leave. My niece was going to go with her mother, but we didn't want them to get trapped on the highway in the storm with the baby. So we thought it would be safer to just stay at the hospital, because we rode out the last hurricane at home, but we sent my niece to the hospital with her baby. That's just been the way it goes, the hospital was the safest place to be if you were going to stay in the city.
首先，我妈妈是必要人员，所以她不能离开。我没有车，所以我不能离开。我侄女原本打算和她妈妈一起走，但我们不想让他们在风暴中的公路上带着孩子被困住。所以我们认为留在医院会更安全，因为我们在家里度过了上一次飓风，但我们把侄女送到了医院。一直以来都是这样，如果你要留在城里，医院是最安全的地方。
So you walk back to the hospital, and what do you find there?
所以你走回医院，你发现了什么？
Well, there's a lot of people roaming around with their kids, and we're sharing food, and we're having a good old time just waiting for a chance to go back home. Then the levees broke. And the next morning, I was able to go back to the house, because I wanted to pick up my degrees, I earned them. I wanted to make sure they weren't wet. And frankly, I was looking for a carton of cigarettes that I knew was in that house somewhere.
嗯，有很多带着孩子的人在四处徘徊，我们分享食物，我们度过了一段美好的时光，只是在等待回家的机会。然后大堤决口了。第二天早上，我能够回到房子里，因为我想拿回我的学位证书，那是我辛苦赚来的。我想确保它们没有湿。坦率地说，我在找一盒我知道在房子里某个地方的香烟。
And so did you find the cigarettes?
那你找到香烟了吗？
I found the cigarettes.
我找到了香烟。
And were they dry?
它们干了吗？
And I found my degrees. And I grabbed my vital papers, my social security card, my-- none of that was wet, because it was in a little purse. And I brought my vital papers back to the hospital, and my mom is saying, we're going to go back to the house to go get theirs. But the water started rising, so within a couple of hours, you weren't able to get back to the house. It just kept rising. We thought, OK, now we're trapped in here, and we don't know how high this water is going to get. So it finally covered the basement, so the generators went out. It covered the first floor.
我找到了我的学位证书。我抓住了我重要的文件，我的社会保障卡，我的——它们都没有湿，因为它们放在一个小钱包里。我把重要的文件带回了医院，我妈妈说我们要回房子去拿他们的。但水位开始上涨，所以几个小时内，你就没法回到房子了。水位一直在涨。我们想，好吧，现在我们被困在这里了，不知道水会涨多高。最后它淹没了地下室，发电机停了。它淹没了一楼。
And when you say cover the first floor, was it actually coming inside the hospital building?
当你提到淹没一楼时，水实际上是流进了医院大楼吗？
Yeah. So the heartbreaking thing was watching them turn people away who had waded through that water to get to the hospital for safe haven. It was amazing. It was heartbreaking.
是的。所以最令人心碎的事情就是看着他们把那些涉水来到医院寻求避难的人拒之门外。这太令人惊讶了。这太令人心碎了。
How often do you see that?
你多久能看到一次这种情况？
That happened over and over again. The person who sticks out most in my mind is a man who had his wife and his two children, and his baby-- his daughter was so dehydrated. The people were yelling at him, you can't come in here. We were on the smoking patio, which is on the second floor, so we saw them. And we were yelling at them, man, leave the baby. Man, leave the baby. And he was like, I can't leave my baby. We don't have a house. How am I going to find my baby if I leave him with you? I don't know where you're going to take him. I've been in this water for two days. It was just devastating to just see that.
这种情况一次又一次地发生。我脑海中最深刻的人是一个带着妻子和两个孩子的男人，他的女儿严重脱水。人们对他喊着，你不能进来。我们在二楼的吸烟露台上，所以我们看到了他们。我们对他们喊着，伙计，留下孩子。伙计，留下孩子。他说，我不能留下我的孩子。我们没有房子。如果我把他留给你们，我怎么找到我的孩子？我不知道你们要带他去哪。我在水里待了两天了。看到这一幕简直太令人崩溃了。
We knew that nobody was going to be able to come up in there. And so the people on the smoking balcony, we would throw them water, and we tried to throw them food.
我们知道没有人能上去。所以吸烟露台上的人会扔给他们水，我们试着扔给他们食物。
And where'd they send him to?
他们把他送到哪去了？
I don't know. We don't know where he went. But I did find out later that they were letting in people with gunshot wounds and snake bites, so it wasn't like they turned everybody away. It was just that, I guess they were thinking we got 3,000 people in this hospital we have to evacuate, we cannot take on any more responsibility. So I understood why they had to turn them away. It was just heartbreaking to see.
我不知道。我们不知道他去了哪。但我后来确实发现他们让那些有枪伤和蛇咬伤的人进去了，所以并不是每个人都被拒之门外。只是我觉得他们想的是，我们医院里有3000人需要撤离，我们不能再承担更多的责任了。所以我理解他们为什么要拒绝他们。看到这一幕真是让人心碎。
So you are in hospital until-- and there's no power in the hospital, but there's water, and it sounds like there's food too.
所以你一直待在医院直到——医院没有电，但有水，听起来还有食物。
We didn't have water after that first night.
在那天晚上之后我们就没水了。
Oh really?
哦，真的吗？
Yeah, we ran out of everything, because people were sharing with each other, and we just thought we'd be able to go home in a minute. That's the thing. It's like, you survived the hurricane. I was a happy camper, because I'd been more scared than I'd ever been in my life, and I walked out of there. So who knew?
是的，我们什么都用完了，因为人们在互相分享，我们以为一会儿就能回家。就是这样。就像，你熬过了飓风。我当时很开心，因为我经历了生命中最恐惧的时刻，我走出了那里。所以谁知道呢？
So how long were you in the hospital? How many days? When did you get out?
那你待在医院多久？多少天？你什么时候出来的？
Two days, and then we were transported to that corner. And what we heard is that we were going to be dropped off by boat to a corner, and the buses will pick us up, and we'll be heading to Texas. That's what we were told.
两天，然后我们被送到了那个路口。我们听到的是，我们会被船送到一个路口，会有公交车接我们，我们要去德克萨斯州。这就是我们被告知的。
And then the buses come in and they take you where?
然后公交车来了，带你们去哪了？
It wasn't buses. The police had to commandeer vehicles. They were asking people in the crowd if they knew how to drive trucks and buses. They were stealing them. The police had to steal vehicles. And so it was totally different than what we anticipated.
不是公交车。警察不得不征用车辆。他们问人群中谁知道怎么开卡车和公交车。他们在偷这些车。警察不得不偷车。所以这与我们预期的完全不同。
So wait, they're just taking any random truck and hotwiring it?
等等，他们只是随机找一辆卡车并直接启动引擎吗？
School buses. Yeah.
校车。是的。
And so what was the vehicle that you got to the next place in? What were you in?
那你们去下一个地方坐的是什么车？你们在什么里面？
There was a key and lock van.
是一辆锁匠的面包车。
Right, a locksmith?
对，一个锁匠？
Yeah, that happened to be driving around, and the police made him start taking us.
是的，他碰巧开车路过，警察让他开始载我们。
And then you go to where?
然后你们去了哪里？
We go to the convention center. And when we arrived, there were people all over the street, under the bridge. And we're like, why are these people on the street? Why aren't they in the convention center? And when we got there, people were saying, you don't want to go in there.
我们去了会展中心。当我们到达时，街上到处都是人，在桥下。我们想，为什么这些人都在街上？他们为什么不在会展中心里面？当我们到达那里时，人们说，你们不想进去。
Did you go inside at all?
你们进去过吗？
Not until the next day.
直到第二天。
What did you see?
你看到了什么？
Inside?
里面吗？
Yeah.
对。
A sewer. A sewer, literally, because I had to use the bathroom, and I was like, where's the bathroom? So I went inside, the whole place was a bathroom. I was stepping in feces, stepping in urine all over the carpets. I used to work as the convention center. That was hard to see. It was a beautiful building. It was a toilet, and people were sitting close as they could to the doors, but the smell was overwhelming.
一个下水道。一个真正的下水道，因为我不得不上厕所，我在想，厕所在哪？所以我进去了，整个地方就是一个厕所。我踩在粪便里，地毯上到处都是尿液。我以前在会展中心工作过。那很难受。那曾经是一座漂亮的建筑。它现在成了厕所，人们尽可能坐在离门口近的地方，但味道太难闻了。
So then what do you do? What's the best you can do?
那你们后来怎么办？你能做的最好的是什么？
I actually stopped eating the minute we got there. I wouldn't eat or drink anything, because I figured if you don't put nothing in, nothing's coming out. I was in the Army. But even after that, I still had to use the bathroom. It was ridiculous. So what I ended up doing was getting a cup, going behind a partition, having a guy guard me while I was relieving myself in a cup behind some partition at the convention center. And I got all kinds of stuff on my feet. Thank God it started raining, because I have a really sensitive nose. I was sitting down, and I could smell the crap on my feet.
我实际上到了那里后就停止进食了。我什么都不吃也不喝，因为我想如果你什么都不吃，就不会有排泄物。我以前在部队服役过。但即便如此，我还是得上厕所。这太荒谬了。所以我最后做的是拿个杯子，躲到一个隔断后面，让一个男人帮我守着，我在会展中心的一个隔断后面用杯子排泄。我的脚上粘上了各种东西。感谢上帝下雨了，因为我的鼻子非常敏感。我坐着，能闻到脚上的排泄物味。
And where did you all sleep?
你们都在哪里睡觉？
We slept on the sidewalk. This place, there was trash all over the ground outside, and I was thinking, how are the girls going to even lay down with their babies? There's not a spot that's clean, nothing. There's nowhere to lay down. And then my mom wanted me to make sure I tell you, what they kept doing the whole time was tell us to line up for the buses that never came. It was like they were doing drills every four hours. You all have to line up for the bus. And if you bum rush the bus, they're just going to take off without you, and nobody is going to get to go anywhere. You have to line up. You have to be in a straight line. We're talking about old people in wheelchairs and women with babies in lines, waiting for buses that you know God damn well aren't coming, like they were playing with us.
我们睡在人行道上。这个地方，外面到处都是垃圾，我在想，女孩们怎么和她们的宝宝躺下？没有一个干净的地方，什么都没有。没有地方可以躺下。然后我妈让我一定要告诉你，他们全程一直在做的事情就是叫我们排队去等永远不会来的公交车。就像他们每四个小时就在搞演习。你们都必须排队上车。如果你冲向车，他们就会直接丢下你们开走，没有人能去任何地方。你们必须排队。你们必须站成直线。我们说的是坐在轮椅上的老人和带着孩子的妇女，在队伍里等着那些你们明知道根本不会来的公交车，就像他们在戏弄我们一样。
I figured it out early in the morning, but what am I supposed to do? Make an announcement? The buses aren't coming. And so I walked up to the so-called head guy in charge of our section, and I told him, I said, why do you have these people sitting out here in the sun, and you know these buses aren't coming? The buses are coming. I said, you're just playing with us. Who gives you the authority to keep lining us up like this, to stand in this heat? He was like, well, I know the guy who can make the call for the buses. I said, well, why hasn't he called them? People are dying.
我清晨就发现了，但我能做什么？发布公告吗？公交车不会来了。所以我走到那个所谓的负责我们区域的领头人那里，告诉他，我说，你为什么要让这些人坐在太阳底下，而且你知道这些公交车不会来？公交车会来的。我说，你们只是在戏弄我们。谁给你们的权力让我们像这样排队，站在烈日下？他说，嗯，我认识那个能决定公交车的人。我说，那他为什么不打电话叫车？人们正在死去。
He said, I wish I could tell you what you wanted to hear. I said, I want to hear the truth. Are the buses coming or not? We need to get these old people and these babies out of this heat. And he just walked away, and we were left there, without help, without food, without water, without sanitary conditions, as if it's perfectly all right for these animals to reside in a fricking sewer like rats. Because there was nothing but black people back there. [BLEEP] disposable. And then, the story became they left us here to die, they're going to kill us.
他说，我希望我能告诉你你想听的话。我说，我想听真相。公交车到底来不来？我们需要把这些老人和孩子从这炎热中解救出来。他只是走开了，我们被留在了那里，没有帮助，没有食物，没有水，没有卫生条件，仿佛这些动物住在像老鼠一样的臭水沟里完全没问题。因为后面全是黑人。[消音] 一次性的。然后，故事变成了他们把我们留在这里等死，他们要杀了我们。
You mean that's what people were saying to each other?
你是说那是人们在互相说的话吗？
Yes.
是的。
And is that what you believed?
那是你所相信的吗？
I was almost convinced, because I kept having a vision of them opening that floodgate on us, of my niece and her baby floating away from me screaming. And I just knew it. And then the next morning, I heard from somebody that they actually were going to open that floodgate. So by the time the rumor started that the National Guard was going to kill us, I almost halfway believed it.
我几乎相信了，因为我不断产生一种幻觉，他们要对我们打开防洪闸，我的侄女和她的宝宝尖叫着从我身边漂走。我只是知道了。然后第二天早上，我从某人那里听说他们真的要打开那个防洪闸。所以当国民警卫队要杀了我们的谣言开始时，我几乎半信半疑。
And so people were saying, basically they just brought us here, they're going to leave us here to die?
所以人们在说，基本上他们只是把我们带到这里，他们要留我们在这里等死？
Yeah, that's what we thought. The police kept passing us by, and the National Guard kept passing us by with their guns pointed at us. When you see a truck full of water, and people have been crying for water for a day and a night, and the water truck passes you by, just keeps going, how are we supposed to believe that these people were here to help us? It was almost like they were taunting us. And then, don't forget they kept lining us up for buses that never showed up. We thought they were playing with us in a best case scenario. In a worst case scenario, they wanted us to either kill each other or die. Or they were going to kill us.
是的，我们就是这么想的。警察不断地从我们身边经过，国民警卫队用枪指着我们也从我们身边经过。当你看到一辆装满水的卡车，而人们已经哭着要了一天一夜的水了，而这辆水车从你身边经过，一直不停，我们怎么能相信这些人是来帮助我们的？就像他们在戏弄我们一样。还有，别忘了他们不断让我们为永远不来的公交车排队。我们以为最好的情况是他们在戏弄我们。最坏的情况是，他们想让我们自相残杀或者死去。或者他们打算杀了我们。
So we keep hearing in the news about violence inside the convention center, and people getting killed, and women being raped. Did you know about any of that when you were there?
我们一直在新闻里听到关于会展中心内的暴力事件，人们被杀，妇女被强奸。你在那里的时候知道这些事吗？
The convention center is section A through J, I believe. We were about at H, and we could hear kind of craziness going on on the further ends in either direction. But where we are was mostly old people and women with children, and I didn't see anybody get raped. I did see people die. I saw one man die, and I saw a girl and her baby die. But I didn't see anybody getting hurt.
会展中心是从A区到J区，我想。我们在H区左右，我们能听到两端远处传来的疯狂声音。但我们所在的地方大多是老人和带着孩子的妇女，我没看到任何人被强奸。我确实看到有人死了。我看到一个男人死了，看到一个女孩和她的宝宝死了。但我没看到有人受伤害。
And talk about, there were men just kind of like roaming with guns, packs of men.
谈谈关于那些带着枪的男人，成群结队的男人。
They were securing the area. Criminals, these guys were criminals, they were. But somehow these guys got together, figured out who had guns, and decided they were going to make sure that no women were getting raped, because we did hear about the women get raped in the Superdome, and that nobody was hurting babies, and nobody was hurting these old people.
他们在保卫区域。罪犯，这些人是罪犯，他们确实是。但以某种方式，这些人聚在一起，找出谁有枪，并决定他们要确保没有妇女被强奸，因为我们确实听说过妇女在超级巨蛋被强奸，没有人伤害婴儿，没有人伤害老人。
They were the ones getting juice for the babies. They were the ones getting clothes for people that walked through that water. They were the ones fanning the old people, because that's what moved the guys, the gangster guys the most, the plight of the old people. That's what haunted me the most, seeing those old people sitting in them chairs, and not being able to get up and walk around or nothing.
是他们负责为宝宝找果汁。是他们为那些涉水经过的人找衣服。是他们为老人扇风，因为那些黑帮成员最受触动的就是老人的处境。最困扰我的是看到那些坐在椅子上的老人，无法站起来走动。
And so these were just guys from the neighborhood?
所以这些只是来自社区的人？
Mm-hmm.
嗯哼。
What else were they doing?
他们还做了什么？
They started looting on Saint Charles and Napoleon. There was a Rite-Aid there. And you would think that they would be stealing stuff that, you know, fun stuff or whatever, because it's a free city, according to them. But they were taking juice for the baby, water, beer for the older people, food, raincoats so that they could all be seen by each other and stuff. And I thought it was pretty cool and very well organized.
他们在圣查尔斯大街和拿破仑大街开始抢劫。那里有一家来爱德药店。你可能会认为他们会偷那些好玩的东西之类的，因为按他们的话说这是一个自由的城市。但他们拿的是给宝宝的果汁、水、给老人的啤酒、食物、雨衣，这样他们就能互相看到对方之类的。我觉得这很酷，组织得非常好。
And did you see this yourself, these guys?
你亲眼看到这些人了吗？
Yeah, I was right there.
是的，我就在旁边。
And so basically, they went off to this Rite-Aid, they got the stuff, they brought it back and started distributing it?
基本上，他们去了那家药店，拿了东西，带回来分发？
Mm-hmm.
嗯哼。
Like Robin Hood?
像罗宾汉一样？
Yeah, exactly like Robin Hood. And that's why I got so mad, because they're calling these guys animals. These guys. That's what got to me, because I know what they did. You're calling these people animals? Come on. And I saw what they did, and I was really touched by it, and I liked the way that they were organized about it, and that they were thoughtful about it. Because they had families they couldn't find too, and that they would put themselves out like that on other people's behalf.
是的，完全像罗宾汉。这就是为什么我很生气，因为他们称这些人是动物。这些人。这就是让我气愤的地方，因为我知道他们做了什么。你们称这些人是动物？得了吧。我看到了他们的所作所为，我对此深受触动，我喜欢他们组织的方式，喜欢他们对此所表现出的深思熟虑。因为他们也有找不到的家人，他们能为了别人的利益而挺身而出。
I never had a real high opinion of thugs myself. But I tell you one thing, I'll never look at them the same way again.
我本人对暴徒从来没有好感。但我告诉你一件事，我永远不会再用同样的眼光看他们了。
Why didn't people just walk away? That's what I don't understand.
为什么人们不直接走开？我不明白。
We weren't allowed. People kept trying to go up the bridge, so they could go to Algiers, and they'd be turned away, and they'd be sent back down.
我们不允许。人们不断试图走上大桥，想去阿尔及尔，但他们被转回来，被遣送下桥。
And literally, they would just like go a couple streets away, and somebody would send them back?
他们真的只是走了几条街，就有人把他们赶回来？
They'd go up the bridge to go across to the West Bank where it was dry and lights were on. And the National Guard was up there with guns. They turned them back with guns, and the Governor gave orders to shoot to kill. You couldn't get through them.
他们上大桥想穿过河到西岸，那里干爽且灯火通明。国民警卫队带着枪站在上面。他们用枪把人们赶了回来，州长下令格杀勿论。你无法穿过他们。
So people would go up the bridge. Every time they lined us up for the buses, and buses wouldn't come, people in groups would go up the bridge, trying to get across the river. People who had family across the river couldn't get across the river. They were not letting us out of there. They wasn't letting nobody in. So we were trapped. I can't even express it. The tears get close to my eyes, and I have this feeling in the pit in my stomach like if I start crying, the sobs will kill me. I guess someday it'll calm down, and I'll be able to just cry like a normal person. But I feel like if I started crying, I'd never stop.
所以人们会上大桥。每次他们让我们排队等公交车，公交车不来时，人们就会成群结队地上桥，试图过河。那些在河对岸有家人的民众无法过河。他们不让我们离开那里。他们不让任何人进去。所以我们被困住了。我甚至无法表达。泪水涌向我的眼睛，我的心底有一种感觉，如果我开始哭，抽泣会杀死我。我想总有一天我会平静下来，能像正常人一样哭。但我感觉如果我开始哭，我就永远不会停下来。
Denise Moore, she's now in Baton Rouge, she's OK, she's just found a new job there.
丹妮丝·摩尔，她现在在巴吞鲁日，她很好，刚在那里找到了一份新工作。
[MUSIC - "WHEN THE LEVEE BREAKS" BY MEMPHIS MINNIE]
[音乐 - 孟菲斯·明妮的《当大堤决口时》]
Act Two, Forgotten, But Not Lost. Let's return to that bridge. You know that bridge that Denise talked about in act one, that people got to the bridge and they were turned back by armed police officers? What exactly happened on that bridge? We wondered about that, and so in this act, we return to that bridge. People in this story were in New Orleans for a paramedics convention. They're out of towners. They were staying at a hotel in the French Quarter. And as the storm approached, there were no flights out of the city, there were no rental cars available. And so they stayed in their hotel, luckily their hotel let them stay. No electricity, eating boxed cereal, canned soup, whatever they had there in the hotel.
第二幕，被遗忘，但未迷失。让我们回到那座桥。你知道丹妮丝在第一幕中谈到的那座桥吗？人们到了桥上却被武装警察赶了回来？在那座桥上到底发生了什么？我们对那件事感到好奇，所以在这一幕中，我们回到那座桥。在这个故事里的人在新奥尔良参加一个辅助医护人员大会。他们是外地人。他们住在法国区的一家酒店。随着风暴临近，没有航班离开这座城市，也没有租车。所以他们留在了酒店里，幸运的是他们的酒店让他们留下了。没有电，吃着盒装麦片、罐头汤，酒店里有什么就吃什么。
And then three days after Katrina hit, one of the hotel managers actually decided to take matters into his own hands, and took up a collection from his guests to raise $25,000 to charter a bunch of private buses to get these people out. And so all that day, guests are getting reports that buses are coming, and all these reports. And they were told to line up and wait for the buses. And then five or six hours after they were told to line up and wait, around midnight they heard word that no, the buses had been commandeered by the military as they entered the city.
然后在卡特里娜飓风袭击三天后，一位酒店经理决定采取行动，向住客募集了2.5万美元，包了几辆私人巴士来把这些人运出去。所以那天整整一天，客人们都得到消息说公交车要来了。他们被告知排队等车。然后在被告知排队等车的五六个小时后，大约在午夜，他们听到消息说，不，公交车在进入城市时被军方征用了。
OK, so the next morning, the hotel is out of food, they're out of water. They basically said, everybody, you got to go now. Lorrie Beth Slonsky and her husband Larry Bradshaw, they're both paramedics from San Francisco, they set off with about 200 other hotel guests that morning for the command center that the police had set up down the street at Harrah's Casino. They go there and they asked the police, what should they do now? Lorrie Beth talked to producer Alex Blumberg.
好吧，第二天早上，酒店没有食物了，也没有水了。他们基本上说，所有人，你们现在必须走了。洛丽·贝丝·斯隆斯基和她的丈夫拉里·布拉德肖，他们都是来自旧金山的医护人员，那天早上和大约200名其他酒店住客出发前往警察在街头的哈拉斯赌场设立的指挥中心。他们去那里询问警察现在该怎么办？洛丽·贝丝和制片人亚历克斯·布隆伯格交谈。
They said you can't go to the Superdome. You cannot go to the convention center. We said, where can we go? They said, we don't know. You are on your own. And that's when we decide, let's camp in front of the police command center in front of Harrah's. There'd be protection, we'd have each other until the next day. Then the police command center realized they had an issue on their hand. They have 200 tourists in front of their command center, so he said, wait, I just heard word. If you cross the bridge, there are buses.
他们说你们不能去超级巨蛋。你们不能去会展中心。我们问，我们能去哪？他们说，我们不知道。你们得自求多福了。就在那时我们决定，就在哈拉斯赌场外的警察指挥中心前露营。会有保护，我们直到第二天都能在一起。然后警察指挥中心意识到他们手头有个难题。他们指挥中心前有200名游客，所以他说，等等，我刚刚听到消息。如果你过桥，那里有公交车。
And a big cheer went up, but Larry, being the realist that he is, said wait a minute, wait a minute. We have been lied to. Monday, Tuesday, Wednesday, today is Thursday. We really would like some guarantee that this is true. And he looked us in the eye and said, I swear to you. There are buses on the bridge. I just got word.
人群爆发出一阵欢呼，但拉里作为一个现实主义者说，等等，等等。我们已经被骗了。周一、周二、周三，今天是周四。我们确实需要一些保证这是真的。他看着我们的眼睛说，我向你们发誓。桥上有公交车。我刚得到消息。
Now where is the bridge at this point from where you're standing?
那此时从你们站的地方看，桥在哪里？
It's two miles through town. It's called the Pontchartrain Expressway. So the 200 of us little tourist types, with our pull along baggage, made our way through the rainy weather.
穿过城镇两英里。它叫庞恰特雷恩高速公路。所以我们这200名小游客，带着拉杆行李，穿过雨天。
And you're all carrying your pull along baggage?
你们都在带着拉杆行李？
I'm still carrying my pull along baggage, with our laptop, and our little Palm Pilot, and our little extra food, and everything. So we are going through town, and people saw us and thought, hmm, here comes some folks. They must know something, so our numbers doubled from probably 200, and then it doubled again, so we were probably about 800 to 1,000 people marching up to the bridge.
我还在带着我的拉杆行李，还有我们的笔记本电脑，我们的小掌上电脑，我们的一点额外食物，以及所有东西。所以我们穿过城镇，人们看到我们并想，嗯，这些人来了。他们一定知道些什么，所以我们的数字从大约200人翻了一番，然后又翻了一番，所以我们大概有800到1000人行进到桥上。
When we got to the bridge, there was the armed Gretna sheriffs, and they had formed a line at the foot of the bridge. So even before we could even explain what we wanted, or what we had heard, that's when they began firing the weapons. Gretna police shot at us and said, get away, get away. You cannot come on the bridge.
当我们到达桥上时，武装的格雷特纳警长在那里，他们在桥脚下形成了一条线。所以甚至在我们还没来得及解释我们要什么，或者我们听到了什么之前，他们就开始开火了。格雷特纳警察向我们射击并说，滚开，滚开。你们不能上桥。
This bridge goes across the Mississippi River to a town called Gretna in neighboring Jefferson Parish. The entire region across the river is called the West Bank. Debbie Zelinsky, a 24 year old sales agent from Boston, was another guest at the Monteleone. She'd been on vacation in New Orleans with a group of five, her friend Sharon and Rashida, Rashida's mother and 13 year old brother, and Rashida's brother's 15 year old friend.
这座桥横跨密西西比河，通往邻近杰斐逊教区的格雷特纳镇。河对岸的整个区域被称为西岸。24岁的波士顿销售代理黛比·泽林斯基是蒙特利昂酒店的另一位住客。她和一群五个人在新奥尔良度假，她的朋友莎朗和拉希达，拉希达的母亲和13岁的弟弟，还有拉希达弟弟的15岁朋友。
The cops were just firing into the air to get people back. They had guns pointed in people's faces, telling them to get back down, or they will shoot you.
警察只是向空中射击以赶走人们。他们用枪指着人们的脸，告诉他们退回去，否则他们会开枪。
And what was your thinking at that moment? What did you make of that? What were you thinking?
在那一刻你有什么想法？你觉得这是怎么回事？你在想什么？
At that point, it was pouring rain. We were soaked through. I thought, I'm never getting out of here. If I am getting out of here, it's not going to be alive. Tears started rolling down my face at that point.
在那一刻，正下着大雨。我们全身湿透。我想，我永远也离不开这里了。如果我能离开这里，我也不会活着出去了。泪水就在那时顺着我的脸流了下来。
It just sounds so crazy to me that there's like a bunch of tired people trying to walk out of a city, and people are shooting. Did it just seem insane to you?
这对我来说听起来太疯狂了，一群疲惫的人试图步行离开一座城市，而人们却在开枪。这在你看来不是很疯狂吗？
It did. I mean, here you have a six lane highway bridge, and there's barely any traffic going out, and you won't let pedestrians cross it? Why?
确实。我是说，这里有一座六车道的高速公路大桥，几乎没有什么车离开，而你们却不让行人穿过它？为什么？
What did I really think? Or do you want--?
我真正是怎么想的？或者你想要——？
Yeah, what did you really think?
是的，你真正是怎么想的？
What I thought was are they serious? They must be mistaken. They could not be shooting at a group of desperate ass people. But apparently they were serious. But we were so desperate. We got to get out of here. This is our only way out. We can't go to the Superdome, we can't go to the convention center. We're scared to death for our lives, and for the people around us lives, that we had to approach them. So my partner Larry had his badge with him, his fire department badge. So he would raise it up, lay it on the ground, put our hands up, and walk backwards and say, may we approach?
我想的是他们是认真的吗？他们一定是弄错了。他们不可能在向一群绝望的人开枪。但显然他们是认真的。但我们太绝望了。我们必须离开这里。这是我们唯一的出路。我们不能去超级巨蛋，我们不能去会展中心。我们为我们的生命，以及周围人的生命感到无比恐惧，我们必须接近他们。所以我伴侣拉里带着他的徽章，消防局的徽章。所以他会举起它，放在地上，举起我们的双手，向后退，说，我们可以接近吗？
And when we approached and had them in conversation, the sheriff informed us that there were no buses, that the police commander had lied to us. And when Larry questioned, it's like, can we just ask you why we can't cross the bridge? Because there was no traffic. There was very little traffic on this six lane highway. And they said that you are not crossing this bridge. We are not turning the West Bank into another Superdome.
当我们走近并和他们谈话时，警长通知我们没有公交车，警察指挥官对我们撒了谎。当拉里质问时，比如，我们能问问为什么我们不能过桥吗？因为没有交通。在这条六车道的高速公路上几乎没什么车。他们说你们不能过这座桥。我们不会把西岸变成另一个超级巨蛋。
And to us, when they said that was absolutely these are code words for, if you're poor and you're black, you are not getting out of New Orleans. You are not coming to our territory.
对我们来说，当他们说那句话时，绝对是暗语，意思就是：如果你贫穷且是黑人，你就不能离开新奥尔良。你们不能进入我们的领地。
It does seem hard to avoid sort of talking about race here.
这里似乎很难避免谈论种族问题。
Yes. We're white, and everybody else that might-- most every other person was African American. And that is what they saw, and that is what they were responding to, that this group of people of color were not going to come into their neighborhoods.
是的。我们是白人，而其他人——几乎每一个其他人都是非裔美国人。这就是他们看到的，这就是他们所回应的，这群有色人种不能进入他们的社区。
Lorrie Beth is kind of a take charge person from what we saw. And we were like, well, we need to stick with someone. We don't know our way, what we're going to do, so we decided, hey, we're sticking with you. We're not leaving you. And glad we didn't.
洛丽·贝丝是一个很有主见的人，从我们所看到的来看。我们心想，我们需要和某人待在一起。我们不知道路，不知道该怎么做，所以我们决定，嘿，我们跟着你。我们不离开你。很高兴我们没有离开。
Our small group of eight, and then other folks as well, we retreated back down Highway 90, and we were trying to find some shelter in the overpass. And then we had these discussions, God, what are we going to do? And what we decided to do was, there was this concrete embankment. If you go onto the middle of Pontchartrain Expressway, there's a center divide. But with the center divide, there was two hunks of concrete that sort of make a nice enclave, and we thought, this will be perfect. It's safe, and we'll be visible to everyone. And certainly, someone's going to come rescue us, and that we'll have security by being on this elevated freeway. And then we can wait for these buses that were certainly going to come get us.
我们八人的小组，还有其他人，撤退回90号公路，试图在立交桥下找点庇护所。然后我们讨论，上帝，我们该怎么办？我们决定做的是，那里有个混凝土路堤。如果你走进庞恰特雷恩高速公路中间，有个中央隔离带。但在中央隔离带里，有两块混凝土形成了不错的避风港，我们想，这太完美了。它很安全，而且大家都能看到我们。当然，有人会来救援我们，而且待在这座高架高速公路上我们会有安全感。然后我们可以等待那些肯定会来接我们的公交车。
This group turned into about, I'd say about 60 or 70 people. And we cleaned up the area so it was safe for the children. And someone had a bag, and we cleaned that up. And I said I had water, and someone else had water, and we kind of made this community. And this is when somebody-- blessed are the people who loot-- got a huge water truck they had stolen. And he had a man and his wife and child, and they were African American, and they unloaded all the water that they had.
这群人增加到大约60或70人。我们清理了区域，所以这对孩子们来说很安全。有人有个袋子，我们把它清理干净。我说我有水，别人也有水，我们形成了这样一个社区。就在这时有人——祝福那些抢劫的人——弄到了一辆他们偷来的大型水车。他带着他的妻子和孩子，他们是非裔美国人，他们卸下了所有的水。
So wait. So a guy came up? A guy just came up to you?
等等。所以一个人过来了？一个人就这样走向你们？
A guy was escaping New Orleans. And that's what it felt like, people were escaping New Orleans. And he drove up to the middle of this Pontchartrain Expressway, drove right up to our encampment, because he saw like 70, 80, 90 people. And he just took all the water out and gave it to us, and then filled the truck up back with human beings, as many older and children that we could get on with their parents on to this, and they drove away. And that is how we got water.
一个人正在逃离新奥尔良。这就是当时的感觉，人们在逃离新奥尔良。他开车来到庞恰特雷恩高速公路中间，直接开到我们的营地，因为他看到大约70、80、90个人。他只是把所有的水拿出来给我们，然后又把卡车装满了人类，尽可能多地把老人和孩子，和他们的父母一起装上去，然后他们开车离开了。这就是我们得到水的方式。
What did he say to you? That's incredible. What did he say?
他对你们说了什么？太不可思议了。他说了什么？
Good luck, brothers and sisters. Good luck. We wish you the best. We can only take what we can take. And we thanked him, and off they go with the families. And then up the street quite a way, there is a National Guard truck that apparently took too sharp of a turn. And you can just see the food fall out of the-- c-rations fall out of this truck. So I mean, it just felt like it was phenomenal. We commandeered a couple of the strong young guys and gals to run up there in the shopping carts that people had and gather up the boxes of food and bring it back.
祝你们好运，兄弟姐妹们。祝你们好运。我们祝你们一切顺利。我们只能带走我们能带走的。我们感谢他，然后他们带着家人们走了。在街上很远的地方，有一辆国民警卫队的卡车，显然转弯太急了。你能看到食物从卡车上掉出来——口粮从车上掉出来。所以我的意思是，这感觉真是太不可思议了。我们征用了几个强壮的年轻人，用人们找来的购物推车跑去那里，把这些箱装食物收集起来带回来。
So you're set.
所以你们准备好了。
We were set.
我们准备好了。
You have food. You have water.
你们有食物。你们有水。
We were set. We had food, we had water. We had some sort of shelter. We had a safe place for the kids. And then the kids took the plastic that the water was in, those big plastic containers that hold five gallon drums of water, and brought it over to like a storm drain, and set it up to make bathroom with privacy. And we took one of the five gallon containers of water, and the kids made a sign-- because we still had luggage at this point, in crayons and things-- and made a sign, please keep the bathroom clean. And we had toilet paper and handy wipes.
我们准备好了。我们有食物，有水。我们有某种避难所。我们有给孩子们安全的地方。然后孩子们拿了装水的塑料，那些装五加仑水桶的大塑料容器，把它带到雨水渠那里，设法做了一个有隐私的厕所。我们拿了一个五加仑的水容器，孩子们做了一个标志——因为我们当时还有行李，用蜡笔写着——做了一个标志，请保持厕所清洁。我们还有卫生纸和湿巾。
So you started with a group of eight, and then it grew to 70. Who were some of the stories of the people who are in this little encampment with you?
所以你们从8个人开始，然后增长到70人。在这个小营地里还有谁的故事？
Well, there was this older woman who was diabetic, and had soiled herself. But people came forward with a makeshift Depends diaper type thing. And then there was just the cutest ding dang kids that would call me Auntie. They would be, Auntie wants the coffee. And they were very strict about the garbage, because we hung garbage bags on the rebar. So we were set up brilliantly, until just as it started to turn dark.
嗯，有一位患有糖尿病的老妇人，她弄脏了自己。但人们拿出了临时的成人纸尿裤之类的东西。还有一些最可爱的孩子，他们会叫我“阿姨”。他们会说，阿姨想要咖啡。他们对垃圾非常严格，因为我们把垃圾袋挂在钢筋上。所以我们布置得非常出色，直到天快黑的时候。
A Gretna sheriff came up and just had that crazy look that, as a paramedic, when I see that crazy look, you just find a way to not come in front of that energy. Because he had a gun, and he was pointing and screaming at us, get the [BLEEP] off this freeway. Get the [BLEEP] off this freeway. Like the most insane, crazed, frightened person ever. And we had to leave this place of safety, and went into the dark. And it was martial law by this point, and we had heard it was a shoot to kill policy.
一个格雷特纳警长走过来，带着那种疯狂的眼神，作为一名医护人员，当我看到那种疯狂的眼神时，你只需要想办法不要挡在那股能量前面。因为他拿着枪，指着我们大叫，从这条高速公路上滚[消音]开。从这条高速公路上滚[消音]开。就像最疯狂、失控、惊恐的人一样。我们不得不离开这个安全的地方，进入黑暗。到那时已经是戒严状态，我们听说那是格杀勿论的政策。
So everyone grabbed what they could, and we didn't know where we were going. As we were walking, we turned back and looked, and then you saw a helicopter come very close, and everything that we had had in there actually went flying, as the helicopter's wind took off.
所以每个人抓起能抓的东西，我们不知道我们要去哪。当我们走着时，我们回头看，然后你看到一架直升机飞得非常近，我们那里的所有东西实际上都飞了起来，因为直升机的风力。
So like a police helicopter literally came down to where your camp had been and blew everything away?
所以就像一架警用直升机真的飞到了你们营地所在的地方，把一切都吹走了？
Right.
对。
And you think that was on purpose?
你认为那是故意的？
Oh yeah. So we walked down the bridge, off the highway, and we actually found a bus, an abandoned bus. We had to actually boost someone into a window, because the door was locked. And he unlocked the door from the inside. We all got in. It was right at dark. It was becoming dark outside. We all were told to lay down on the seats and do not lift your head for anything.
哦，是的。所以我们走下大桥，离开高速公路，我们竟然发现了一辆公交车，一辆被遗弃的公交车。我们不得不把某人推到窗户里，因为门被锁了。他从里面打开了门。我们都进去了。天刚黑。外面变黑了。我们都被告知趴在座位上，不管听到什么都不要抬头。
Who told you that?
谁告诉你们的？
My friend's mom. She's like, don't sit up, don't lift your head. I don't care what you hear.
我朋友的妈妈。她说，不要坐起来，不要抬头。不管你听到什么。
What was the fear?
恐惧是什么？
The fear was you could hear gunshots getting closer. You could hear people walking. It was a fear of the gunshots. It was also a fear of the police. We were afraid they'd come. They would probably kick us out, and we didn't want to be out when it was dark out. You could hear the-- I don't know if they were rats or what they were, but they were outside. You could hear them. I think I maybe slept 5 or 10 minutes.
恐惧是你听得到枪声越来越近。你听得到人们走路的声音。那是一种对枪声的恐惧。这也是对警察的恐惧。我们害怕他们会过来。他们可能会把我们赶走，我们不想在天黑的时候待在外面。你听得到——我不知道是老鼠还是什么，但在外面。你听得到它们。我想我可能睡了5或10分钟。
The minute the sun came up, we were out of there. We left the bus. We left a note in the bus saying thank you, we're sorry. And we left. We went up to the bridge to see if they'd let us cross.
太阳一出来，我们就离开了。我们离开了公交车。我们在车里留了一张条子说谢谢，我们很抱歉。然后我们就离开了。我们上桥看看他们会不会让我们过。
Larry had contacted the president of our union and said, OK, we are at the fire department, John Meade and said, OK John, honest to God, it is now dire. We need to get out. And somehow John, through the other union, through a guy who works at Menlo Park, who was working for FEMA, somehow one of those connections happened that the FEMA person got to tell the Gretna police or sheriff to yes, let us eight people go through. It was so early in the morning, but we could see the people starting to come up, because people are trying to still get out.
拉里联系了我们工会的主席，说，好吧，我们在消防局，约翰·米德说，好吧约翰，诚实地说，现在情况很危急。我们需要离开。不知怎么的，约翰通过另一个工会，通过一个在门洛帕克工作、为联邦紧急事务管理局工作的家伙，不知怎么的，那些联系中的一个发生了，那个联邦管理局的人告诉了格雷特纳警察或警长，是的，让我们八个人通过。那天很早，但我们能看到人们开始上来了，因为人们还在试图离开。
And as people were coming up, one of the sheriffs walked down the ramp a bit and shot up past some people and said, do not approach. We got past that. We got the permission. We walked across the bridge.
当人们上来时，其中一名警长沿斜坡走下来一点，向一些人的方向开枪说，不要靠近。我们过去了。我们得到了许可。我们走过了大桥。
That must have been a very-- I mean, on the one hand, you must have been thrilled to be getting out, but was it a little hard?
那一定是非常——我的意思是，一方面，你一定很激动能出去，但那是不是有点难受？
Very demoralized. Very sad. Very unfair. It's really wrong. This makes no sense. All of us should be walking across that bridge. And it's only by this connection, that connection that we were able to get across. How did I feel? I felt really incensed and anger that other people weren't allowed to pass. And at the same time, I felt so fortunate and like I won the lottery that us eight were able to cross.
非常士气低落。非常难过。非常不公平。这真的很错。这毫无意义。我们所有人本都应该走过那座桥。只有通过那种联系，那种联系，我们才能过桥。我感觉如何？我感到非常愤怒，因为其他人不被允许通过。与此同时，我觉得自己非常幸运，像是中了彩票一样，我们八个人能够过桥。
There's one more hurdle actually. In their group of eight, three were white, four were black, Sharon, Rashida, and her mother and brother, and her brother's friend was Puerto Rican. But the authorities had told Larry that only his immediate family was allowed to cross the bridge. So Larry said, this is my immediate family.
其实还有一个障碍。在我们八人的小组中，三个是白人，四个是黑人，莎朗、拉希达、她的母亲和弟弟，还有她弟弟的朋友是波多黎各人。但当局告诉拉里，只有他的直系亲属才被允许过桥。所以拉里说，这是我的直系亲属。
I was his daughter. My friend's mom was his sister in law with her three kids, and my friend's brother's friend was his foster child. And that's how we had to play it off, in order for us to cross the bridge all together.
我是他的女儿。我朋友的妈妈是他的嫂子带着她的三个孩子，我朋友的弟弟的朋友是他的养子。这就是我们不得不演出来的戏码，为了让我们大家一起过桥。
Debbie Zelinsky and Lorrie Beth are now back home in San Francisco and Boston, respectively. They talked to Alex Blumberg.
黛比·泽林斯基和洛丽·贝丝现在分别回到了旧金山和波士顿的家中。她们接受了亚历克斯·布隆伯格的采访。
[MUSIC - "WALKING TO NEW ORLEANS" BY FATS DOMINO]
[音乐 - 胖子多米诺的《步行去新奥尔良》]
Coming up, Fox TV versus a New Orleans 18 year old. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International when our program continues.
接下来，福克斯电视台对比一位新奥尔良的18岁年轻人。节目将在芝加哥公共广播电台和国际公共广播电台的节目继续后一分钟播出。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today's program, After The Flood, New Orleans stories in the aftermath of Hurricane Katrina. We've arrived at act three of our show. Act Three, Social Studies Lesson.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目，《洪水之后》，卡特里娜飓风过后新奥尔良的故事。我们进入了节目的第三幕。第三幕，社会学课。
TV talk show host Bill O'Reilly stated rather directly this week the lessons that he thought conservatives and everybody else should take from the devastation. First he said you can't rely on government. And second he said, the problems that we saw in New Orleans weren't about race, they were about class.
电视脱口秀主持人比尔·奥莱利本周相当直接地陈述了他认为保守派和其他所有人应该从这场破坏中吸取的教训。首先他说你不能依赖政府。其次他说，我们在新奥尔良看到的问题无关种族，而是关于阶级。
If you're poor, you're powerless, not only in America, but everywhere on Earth. You don't have enough money to protect yourself from danger, danger is going to find you. The aftermath of Hurricane Katrina should be taught in every American school. If you don't get educated, if you don't develop a skill and force yourself to work hard, you'll most likely be poor. And sooner or later, you'll be standing on a symbolic rooftop waiting for help. Chances are that help will not be quick in coming.
如果你贫穷，你就是无能为力的，不仅在美国，在地球上的任何地方。你没有足够的钱保护自己免受危险，危险就会找到你。卡特里娜飓风的后果应该在每所美国学校讲授。如果你没有受过教育，如果你没有发展出一项技能并强迫自己努力工作，你很可能会贫穷。迟早，你会站在象征性的屋顶上等待救援。很有可能救援不会很快到来。
Well, our producer Alex Blumberg decided to run this by somebody who is actually in an American high school, 18 year old Ashley Nelson, who is our act, and who lives in the Lafitte housing projects in New Orleans, in one of the neighborhoods that got flooded.
嗯，我们的制片人亚历克斯·布隆伯格决定找一位真正身处美国高中、18岁的阿什利·纳尔逊来谈谈，她是我们的主角，住在新奥尔良的拉菲特公共住宅区，在被洪水淹没的社区之一。
That's what he said?
他真是这么说的？
Yeah. On TV. To you, what's the thing that stands out most about that?
是的。在电视上。对你来说，关于那一点最突出的地方是什么？
Basically, he said if you're rich, you live, if you're poor, you die. I had no idea that it was a crime to be poor, and the punishment was death.
基本上，他说如果你富有，你就活着，如果你贫穷，你就去死。我不知道贫穷是一种犯罪，而惩罚是死亡。
What was the first that you heard about the hurricane, and what preparations did you make?
你第一次听到关于飓风的消息是什么时候，你做了什么准备？
When I heard about the hurricane, it was Saturday, and you know what's supposed to come next, Sunday night. So when I heard about it, I went over to my grandmother's house. My whole family was over there. And I'm like, y'all come on. I'm just so amped up. I'm like, y'all come on. Let's go rent a car. We got to evacuate. There's a hurricane coming. Then everybody looked at me stupid. They're like, all right, you're going to go rent a car, because we have that kind of money to go out of town and we got that kind of money to do that kind of stuff, like being sarcastic about it. And I'm like, man, I forgot we poor. I promise you, that's what I thought in my head. I forgot we were poor.
当我听到关于飓风的消息时，是周六，你知道接下来会发生什么，周日晚上。所以当我听到它时，我去了我祖母家。我全家人都在那。我说，大家快点。我太兴奋了。我说，大家快点。我们去租辆车。我们必须撤离。飓风要来了。然后每个人看我像看傻子一样。他们说，好吧，你去租辆车，因为我们有那种钱去城外，我们有那种钱做那种事，嘲讽地说。我说，天哪，我忘了我们很穷。我向你保证，我脑子里就是这么想的。我忘了我们很穷。
And were there people who were able to get out, who had a car?
有能够离开的人吗，那些有车的人？
Yeah, because I remember that day I was standing outside, and it was a lot of people running from their house to their car, from the house to their car, just throwing stuff in there, throwing stuff in there, trying to hurry up and get out before the traffic gets too hectic. There was a handful of people, and everybody else is just sitting there watching how people leave, and they got to stay. I know that's what I was thinking, when I seen people leaving. I'm like, they leaving and I got to stay. And there's not even an option, I have to stay.
是的，因为我记得那天我站在外面，很多人从房子跑到车里，从房子跑到车里，只是把东西扔进去，扔进去，试图赶快在交通变得太繁忙之前离开。只有少数人，其他人只是坐在那里看着人们离开，他们不得不留下来。我知道当我看到人们离开时我就是这么想的。我说，他们离开了，而我必须留下。甚至没有选择，我必须留下。
Ashley rode out the storm at her father's house in Jefferson Parish, across the river from New Orleans, where the rest of her family was. There wasn't too much flooding there, so the next morning, they went out and found all the scrap wood they could, blown down branches, old fences, and started a fire to cook the little bit of meat they'd been able to buy at the store before the storm came. They figured that would hold them until rescuers got there. But one day past and no one came, then two days. They had no TV. They didn't know what was going on.
阿什利在河对岸新奥尔良杰斐逊教区的父亲家中度过了风暴，她的其他家人都在那里。那里洪水不是很多，所以第二天早上，他们出去找了所有能找到的废木料、吹断的树枝、旧篱笆，生火做了一点风暴来临前他们能在商店买到的少量肉。他们以为这能支撑到救援人员到来。但一天过去了，没有人来，然后两天过去了。他们没有电视。他们不知道发生了什么。
I thought just like my daddy. I thought like my daddy, somebody was coming to help us. Nobody came to help us. No Red Cross trucks, no nothing. I mean, at least they could have dropped us some water. Do you know what it's like to not have water? You get a taste in your mouth that's just horrible. Your mouth is all dry, and you can't even think right. You start getting delusional and hallucinating about things.
我想就像我爸爸一样。我像我爸爸一样思考，有人会来帮助我们。没有人来帮助我们。没有红十字会卡车，什么都没有。我是说，至少他们本可以给我们空投些水。你知道没有水是什么感觉吗？你的嘴里有一种可怕的味道。你的嘴里全干了，你甚至不能正常思考。你开始变得妄想，对事情产生幻觉。
Did you actually have hallucinations?
你真的产生幻觉了吗？
Yeah.
是的。
What did you hallucinate?
你幻觉到了什么？
Water bottles, four water bottles, big Kentwood gallon jugs. I'm serious, I went crazy. I mean, I would just sit down and rock and think about is the world going to turn to hell and we're all going to burn? I mean, I just started going crazy, really crazy.
水瓶，四个水瓶，大肯伍德加仑桶。我是认真的，我疯了。我是说，我只是坐下来摇晃，想着世界是不是要变成地狱，我们都要被烧死了？我是说，我只是开始变得疯狂，真的很疯狂。
Did it make you realize, like so this is what it feels like? This is what it feels like to be starving?
这让你意识到，比如这就是那种感觉吗？这就是挨饿的感觉吗？
I thought that when I was in Jefferson Parish, I thought, man, I'm starving. That's what I said to myself, I'm like man, I'm starving. Like you know how your stomach growls?
我在杰斐逊教区时就这么想过，我对自己说，天哪，我在挨饿。这就是我对自己的说的，天哪，我在挨饿。就像你知道你的肚子怎么咕咕叫吗？
Uh-huh.
嗯哼。
When you're starving, you get cramps in your stomach, and you feel like your stomach just bit into your back. I mean, the best bet is for you to lean forward.
当你挨饿时，你的胃部会痉挛，感觉你的胃就像咬进了你的后背。我是说，最好的办法就是身体前倾。
How scared were you?
你有多害怕？
I thought I was going to die. I look at it like this now. 9/11 was bad because it was terrorists. It's no surprise people hate the United States, it's no big surprise. But New Orleans was worse, because it was our own government who betrayed us. They betrayed us. They betrayed us. They left us there to die. And then you hear George Bush telling the FEMA man, you're doing a good job. What do you mean by that? What do you mean by that? Because I mean, people are dying there. So you're telling him he's doing a good job, what are you saying? That's good that people are dying? I never understood that, and I really wish I can meet him to ask him, what do you mean by that he doing a good job?
我以为我要死了。我现在是这样看的。9/11很糟糕，因为那是恐怖分子。人们憎恨美国并不奇怪，这没什么大惊小怪的。但新奥尔良更糟糕，因为背叛我们的是我们自己的政府。他们背叛了我们。他们背叛了我们。他们把我们留在那等死。然后你听到乔治·布什对那个联邦紧急事务管理局的人说，你干得不错。你这话是什么意思？你这话是什么意思？因为我是说，人们在那里死去。所以你在告诉他他干得不错，你在说什么？人们死去是件好事？我从来不理解这一点，我真的很希望我能见到他问他，你说的“他干得不错”是什么意思？
18 year old Ashley Nelson talking with Alex Blumberg. Two days after that interview, the head of FEMA, the FEMA man, Michael Brown, whom President Bush said was doing such a good job, was removed from all duties relating to Hurricane Katrina.
18岁的阿什利·纳尔逊在和亚历克斯·布隆伯格交谈。那次采访两天后，联邦紧急事务管理局局长，那个布什总统说干得非常出色的布朗，被解除了所有与卡特里娜飓风相关的职务。
[MUSIC - "THEM THAT GOT" BY RAY CHARLES]
[音乐 - 雷·查尔斯的《那些拥有的》]
Act Four, Diaspora. While hundreds of thousands of Gulf residents evacuated after the storm and followed the whole thing from afar, Cheryl Wagner left for Gainesville, Florida. From satellite photos, she could tell her house is flooded. She hears it's seven feet of water. Over this past week, we've gotten dozens of emails at our radio program from people in this situation, and they all pretty much say the same thing, how bizarre it is to be indefinitely exiled from their homes and normal lives, and now to be an evacuee in the larger world.
第四幕，流散。虽然成千上万的海湾居民在风暴后撤离并从远处关注这一切，但谢丽尔·瓦格纳去了佛罗里达州的盖恩斯维尔。从卫星照片上，她可以看出她的房子被淹了。她听说那里有七英尺深的水。在过去这一周，我们电台收到了几十封处于这种情况的人发来的电子邮件，他们几乎都说了同样的话，被无限期流放到家园和正常生活之外，现在成为这个大世界里的撤离人员是多么离奇。
We've been advised that when we go back to New Orleans, my boyfriend and I need to get guns, mean dogs, or both. Which seems ludicrous to me. But people where we evacuated to over here in North Central Florida have offered us a shotgun. We got offered a shotgun before we got offered a generator. One of the people calling to tell us to get a shotgun is a normally laid back musician friend who used to have a weekly gig in the Quarter, singing Cuban love songs in falsetto. A few days ago, he bought a shotgun in Baton Rouge, where he evacuated to, and is now calling my boyfriend and advising us to do the same.
我们被告知，当我们回到新奥尔良时，我和我的男朋友需要弄到枪，凶猛的狗，或者两者都要。这对我来说似乎很荒谬。但我们撤离到的佛罗里达中北部这里的人们给我们提供了一把猎枪。在有人给我们提供发电机之前，我们先被提供了一把猎枪。打电话告诉我们弄一把猎枪的人是一位平时很随和的音乐家朋友，他曾经在法国区有一个每周一次的演出，用假声唱古巴情歌。几天前，他在撤离到的巴吞鲁日买了一把猎枪，现在打电话给我男朋友建议我们也这样做。
I have five dogs, and I'm bringing the meanest looking one back, he says. I just bought a shotgun with a sweet pistol grip. Last week he also called to report rumors that people from New Orleans were raping and looting in the mall in Baton Rouge. You're a person from New Orleans, I thought, but didn't say.
我有五只狗，我正带着最凶的那只回去，他说。我刚买了一把带有漂亮手枪握把的猎枪。上周他还打电话报告谣言，说来自新奥尔良的人在巴吞鲁日的商场里抢劫和强奸。你是来自新奥尔良的人，我想着，但没说出口。
Right after it became clear we were not getting home, I predicted the totally predictable. That people in Baton Rouge would immediately start cringing in the face of what they considered to be the black mongrel hordes and loose people of New Orleans. I say this knowing the people of Baton Rouge and the rest of Louisiana have been breaking their backs with generosity and hospitality and kindness. I know many white and Cajun people and fishermen with air boats helped rescue their black and white New Orleans neighbors from attics. People from Baton Rouge are showing up at hotels and sweetly paying strangers from New Orleans' bills. My mother in Hammond was asked to open up her washing machine to state troopers' underwear.
就在很清楚我们回不了家之后，我预测了完全可预测的事情。巴吞鲁日的人们会立即开始对他们认为的新奥尔良黑人杂种和散漫的人群感到畏缩。我说这话时知道巴吞鲁日和路易斯安那州其他地方的人们一直在以慷慨、好客和善良付出辛劳。我知道许多白人、卡津人和开气垫船的渔民帮助营救了他们的黑人和白人新奥尔良邻居。来自巴吞鲁日的人们出现在酒店，甜美地支付了来自新奥尔良的陌生人的账单。我母亲在哈蒙德被要求打开她的洗衣机，让州警洗他们的内衣。
Still, some folks are giving with one hand and holding a gun with the other. Seems nobody wants a bunch of poor people, black, white, Cajun, whatever, moving to their neck of the woods. Seems it is fear of the have-nots and poor, as much as racism, which of course it also is.
尽管如此，有些人还是这只手给与，那只手拿着枪。似乎没有人想要一群穷人，黑人、白人、卡津人，无论什么人，搬到他们的地盘。似乎这是对贫困和穷人的恐惧，就像种族主义一样，当然这也是种族主义。
So now we're here in Gainesville, listening to New Orleans ex pat news radio and webcasts through tinny computer speakers, squinting to see my watery house on satellite photos, getting crappy emails from friends crying because they killed their cats, and watching TV. Someone desperate called us and said, can you please text message Stan and make him get off his roof? He's up there with Luna and another dog, and won't come down unless they'll take the dogs too.
所以现在我们待在盖恩斯维尔，通过微弱的电脑音箱收听新奥尔良外籍新闻广播和网络直播，眯着眼睛看卫星照片上我那被水淹没的房子，收到朋友们因为杀了他们的猫而哭泣的糟糕邮件，看着电视。有人绝望地给我们打电话说，你能发条短信给斯坦，让他从屋顶下来吗？他和露娜还有另一条狗在上面，除非他们也带上狗，否则他不肯下来。
It's strange to think of all my New Orleans people spit out by the storm, all over the South in country, in Diaspora, getting terrible phone calls and cable TV migraine too. Before the flood, New Orleans was a place where Southerners sent their laid back people who can't, or won't get with the program. Artists, gay relatives, eternal optimists, funny hat wearers, and intellectuals. I'm one of the above, and we're in New Orleans for a reason, to get away from the baptists, but still get to live in the South, where we're from.
想到所有被风暴吐出来的新奥尔良人，散布在南方各处，在流散中，接到可怕的电话和有线电视偏头痛，真是奇怪。洪水前，新奥尔良是一个南方人送去那些懒散的人、无法或不愿融入大集体的人的地方。艺术家、同性恋亲戚、永恒的乐观主义者、喜欢戴有趣帽子的人和知识分子。我就是其中的一员，我们去新奥尔良是有原因的，为了逃离浸信会，但仍然能住在这个我们来自的南方。
But where are Southern outsiders supposed to go who are exiled from their place of exile? I didn't want to arm myself with a gun or a leaf blower to face the future. People ask what it's like to lose your house and your friends and your life and your town, and begin to look scared when you answer. They want to care, but they can't. They look at you, and worry for themselves.
但那些被流放出流放地的南方外人该去哪里呢？我不想用枪或吹叶机来武装自己以面对未来。人们问失去房子、朋友、生活和城镇是什么感觉，当你回答时，他们开始显得害怕。他们想关心，但他们不能。他们看着你，为自己担心。
Drenched in the compulsory cheer of the college town of Gainesville, I feel like a leper from Carville, or the bereaved at a Southern funeral. Family friends slide you white envelopes with money in them, then everyone around you puts on an ugly orange and blue outfit, straps on their foam fingers, and heads out to the Florida Gators football game.
沉浸在盖恩斯维尔大学城的强迫欢庆中，我觉得自己像卡维尔的麻风病人，或者是南方葬礼上的丧亲者。家庭朋友塞给你装钱的白信封，然后周围的每个人都穿上丑陋的橙色和蓝色服装，戴上泡沫手指，去参加佛罗里达短吻鳄橄榄球赛。
Cheryl Wagener normally lives in New Orleans in Mid-City on South Cortez Street. She asks, if someone there has a canoe, please go and check out her house.
谢丽尔·瓦格纳通常住在新奥尔良中城的南科尔特斯街。她问，如果那里有人有独木舟，请去检查一下她的房子。
Act Five, Displaced Persons Camp. Last August, a category four storm, Hurricane Charley, devastated parts of Florida. And FEMA built a big trailer park for people whose homes were destroyed. It was near an airport outside Punta Gorda. At one point, over 550 trailers were there. And when our staff looked into it this week, we were surprised to find out that a full year later, over 500 trailers are still there, with more than 1,000 people. And also just this week, we read that in the New York Times, a FEMA official was saying that these kinds of mobile homes, like in Punta Gorda, outside Punta Gorda, may be the standard for people displaced by Hurricane Katrina. Our producer Lisa Pollack called down there to see what it's like.
第五幕，流离失所者营地。去年八月，一场四级风暴，查理飓风，摧毁了佛罗里达的部分地区。联邦紧急事务管理局为那些房子被毁的人建了一个大型拖车公园。它在蓬塔戈尔达外的一个机场附近。曾经有超过550辆拖车在那里。当我们的工作人员本周查看时，我们惊讶地发现，整整一年后，超过500辆拖车仍然在那里，住着1000多人。而且就在本周，我们读到《纽约时报》报道，一位联邦紧急事务管理局官员说，这种移动房屋，像蓬塔戈尔达那样，蓬塔戈尔达外，可能会成为因卡特里娜飓风而流离失所的人的标准。我们的制片人丽莎·波拉克打电话去那里看看是什么样子的。
Like almost everybody I asked to describe the FEMA mobile home park, Bob Heibert starts with the disclaimer.
像几乎所有我要求描述联邦紧急事务管理局移动房屋公园的人一样，鲍勃·海伯特以免责声明开头。
It is better than no housing. But for some folks, it's very unsettling, it's depressing, it's deplorable.
这比没地方住要好。但对一些人来说，这非常不安，令人沮丧，令人悲惨。
Heibert is the director of hurricane recovery for Charlotte County, Florida. Like everyone else I talked to, he described a dreary mini-city, nothing but endless rows of identical white trailers in a vacant lot by the county airport.
海伯特是佛罗里达州夏洛特县飓风恢复主任。像我交谈过的其他人一样，他描述了一个阴郁的迷你城市，县机场旁边的空地上只有一排排无尽的相同白色拖车。
But it very much is just like a trailer park, a storage place. It's like a manufacturer where they're just all lined up waiting to go, except these are actually occupied and hooked up, and it's a village by itself.
但它确实就像一个拖车公园，一个存储的地方。它就像一个制造商，他们都在排队等待离开，只不过这些实际上是有人居住并接通水电的，它本身就是一个村庄。
It looks kind of like some military camp in the desert.
它看起来有点像沙漠里的某种军事营地。
This is Jennifer. She didn't want to give her last name. She, along with her husband, three kids and a dog, have lived in a FEMA park since just before last Thanksgiving.
这是詹妮弗。她不想透露她的姓。她和她的丈夫、三个孩子和一条狗，自去年感恩节前就一直住在联邦紧急事务管理局公园里。
There's no grass, there's no trees. It's all white, gritty sand. And the wind will whip through the trailers, and you'll just get pelted with sand.
没有草，没有树。全是白色的、粗糙的沙子。风会在拖车间穿行，你会一直被沙子击中。
The FEMA park wasn't supposed to be homey. It was functional. After hurricane Charley destroyed 11,000 residences in the county, lots of people needed places to live, and fast. For that, the trailers were perfect, says Heibert.
联邦紧急事务管理局公园本来就不是为了舒适。它是功能性的。在查理飓风摧毁了该县11000处住所后，许多人需要居住的地方，而且要快。对于这一点，海伯特说，拖车是完美的。
Because they got a lot of people in there in like 30 days, people that were just kind of living in cars because there were no other places for them to go. They were on the streets, or they were living with other people, or whatever. So I mean, it was a lifesaver when it happened.
因为他们在30天内把很多人弄进去了，那些本来因为没地方去而住在车里的人。他们流落街头，或者和别人住在一起，或者无论如何。所以我的意思是，当它发生时，这是一个救星。
Someone called me from FEMA and said, are you still interested in one of the mobile homes? I say, yes I am. And he said, well OK, you need to go down there to the site tomorrow to sign your paperwork. They have a house for you.
联邦紧急事务管理局的人给我打电话说，你还有兴趣要一个移动房屋吗？我说，是的，我有。他说，好的，你需要明天去现场签署文件。他们为你准备了一个房子。
That's Kim. Last December, when she got that phone call, she was desperate and out of options. She, her husband, and four kids rode out the hurricane, huddled in the shower stall at their rental house, the ceilings crumbling above them. After the house has condemned, the family spent two weeks in a crowded homeless shelter. Then came three months in an RV, the kind people tow on vacation, 30 feet long, all six of them living there.
那是金。去年十二月，当她接到那个电话时，她绝望了，别无选择。她、她的丈夫和四个孩子在他们的出租屋淋浴间蜷缩着度过了飓风，天花板在他们上面坍塌。在房子被判定不宜居住后，这家人在拥挤的无家可归者收容所待了两周。然后是在房车里待了三个月，就是那种人们度假时拖着的那种，30英尺长，他们六个人全住在那里。
So by the time they got the FEMA mobile home, 70 feet long with three bedrooms, it seemed like a mansion. They could live rent free, paying only utilities, while they look for a place of their own. The problem is, nine months later, Kim's family is still there. Every month a FEMA agent comes by to ask her what she's done to get out. To keep her lease, she has to prove she's been working on it, and every month she gives the same answer. She's called public housing. She's combed the ads. But in Charlotte County, there's not much that she and her husband, a Wal-Mart manager, can afford. So far, the government's let her stay, but the pressure's getting to her.
所以当他们得到联邦紧急事务管理局的移动房屋时，70英尺长，有三个卧室，它看起来就像一座豪宅。他们可以免租金居住，只需支付水电费，同时寻找自己的地方。问题是，九个月后，金的一家还住在那里。每个月都有联邦紧急事务管理局的特工过来问她为了搬出去做了什么。为了保留租约，她必须证明她一直在努力，每个月她都给出同样的答案。她打过公共住房电话。她翻遍了广告。但在夏洛特县，她和丈夫——一名沃尔玛经理——能负担得起的地方不多。到目前为止，政府让她留下来，但压力快让她崩溃了。
These people that come to our house, and they are on us about what are you doing to get a place? And what are you doing to do this? And what are you doing to do that? It really just irritates a lot of us, because we didn't ask for this, and we're stuck here, and there's nothing else that we can do. And the way they talk to you, it almost makes you feel like you did this to yourself.
这些来到我们家的人，他们紧盯着我们问你在做什么来弄个地方？你在做什么来做这个？你在做什么来做那个？这真的惹恼了我们许多人，因为我们没要求这样，我们被困在这里了，我们无能为力。而且他们和你说话的方式，让你感觉就像是你自己造成了这一切。
The real problem we have is that most of the rental properties were lost in the storm.
我们面临的真正问题是，大多数出租物业在风暴中损失了。
That includes almost all the low income units, says Bob Heibert of the county government.
这包括几乎所有低收入单位，县政府的鲍勃·海伯特说。
The ones that survived suddenly became more expensive and unaffordable, because other people that had the means to pay for them rented those properties. So it's a very long term problem, because unless we can find a way to house those folks in some housing that they can afford, they're going to have to move somewhere else where they can get a house and they can get a job.
那些幸存下来的突然变得更贵且负担不起，因为其他有钱支付的人租了这些房产。所以这是一个非常长期的困扰，因为除非我们能找到办法让这些人住在他们负担得起的住房里，否则他们将不得不搬到其他地方，去那里找房子和工作。
Some places don't want kids.
有些地方不想要孩子。
Jennifer's had problems finding a place too.
詹妮弗在找地方方面也遇到了问题。
We have a dog, and now finding a place that will let us have the dog-- I mean, I know some people don't understand, like, oh, just get rid of the dog and move into one of the apartments that accepts dogs. But after everything my children have been through, moving to two different schools, moving four times in the past year, with everything else that's lost, I couldn't imagine taking their dog away too.
我们有条狗，现在找一个允许我们养狗的地方——我是说，我知道有些人不理解，比如，哦，只要扔掉狗搬进那些接受狗的公寓之一就行了。但在我的孩子们经历了一切之后，搬到两所不同的学校，去年搬了四次家，加上其他失去的一切，我无法想象还要带走他们的狗。
Crime and drugs have been a problem at the FEMA park, and there aren't many places for kids to play. Lots of people stay only because they have no choice, and others, everyone I talked to agreed, aren't really trying that hard. It's easy to imagine that this is what Louisiana could look like a year from now, thousands of people warehoused in trailers, stuck in makeshift camps on the edges of towns. I asked Bob Heibert if he worries about the idea of more FEMA trailer parks like this one, and he says he does.
犯罪和毒品在联邦紧急事务管理局公园一直是个问题，没有多少给孩子玩耍的地方。许多人留下来仅仅是因为他们别无选择，其他人，我交谈过的每个人都同意，并没有真正努力去搬走。很容易想象路易斯安那州一年后可能是什么样子，成千上万的人被安置在拖车里，困在城镇边缘的临时营地中。我问鲍勃·海伯特他是否担心像这样更多的联邦紧急事务管理局拖车公园，他说他担心。
I think what needs to happen is that if they're going to do that, which they will, and it's a good short term solution, they need to think about what happens next month or the month after, like have a phase two plan. They got to very quickly start working on a strategy to break that down and move people on, just for the sake of the people. I mean, what we're really talking about is humanity here. We're talking about human beings that need to get back to some normalcy before they can get over this.
我认为需要发生的是，如果他们要那样做，这他们会做，而且这是一个很好的短期解决方案，他们需要考虑下个月或下下个月会发生什么，比如有一个二阶段计划。他们必须非常迅速地开始制定战略来拆除它并转移人们，仅仅为了人们的利益。我是说，我们在这里真正讨论的是人性。我们在谈论人类需要恢复正常生活才能克服这件事。
So how long is FEMA willing to keep housing hurricane victims? In Punta Gorda, they're giving residents until February, 18 months after the storm. Then, FEMA says, they'll stop funding the trailer park. After that, what happens is up to the county, which is still figuring out what to do. It might help people buy the trailers and relocate them, and it might keep the park open and let people rent. It's not clear exactly how it'll work, or where the money will come from. It's not going to be easy.
那么联邦紧急事务管理局愿意安置飓风受害者多久？在蓬塔戈尔达，他们给居民的时间是到二月，即风暴后18个月。然后，联邦紧急事务管理局说，他们将停止资助拖车公园。在那之后，发生什么取决于县政府，县政府还在想办法解决。它可能帮助人们购买拖车并搬迁，也可能保持公园开放并让人们租住。目前还不清楚具体将如何运作，或者钱将从哪里来。这不会很容易。
Lisa Pollack.
丽莎·波拉克。
Our program was produced today by Julie Snyder, Sarah Koenig, and myself, with Alex Blumberg, Diane Cook, Jane Feltes, Amy O'Leary, and Lisa Pollak. Elizabeth Meister runs our website. Production help from Todd Bachman, Chris Ladd, and Laura Bellows. It is Laura's last day on the program, which is a very, very bad for us, because she's done such good work here. Laura, we all wish you the best.
我们的节目今天由朱莉·斯奈德、萨拉·科尼格和我自己制作，还有亚历克斯·布隆伯格、黛安·库克、简·费尔特斯、艾米·奥利里和丽莎·波拉克。伊丽莎白·迈斯特管理我们的网站。托德·巴赫曼、克里斯·拉德和劳拉·贝洛斯的制作帮助。今天是劳拉在节目组的最后一天，这对我们来说非常非常糟糕，因为她在这里做了这么好的工作。劳拉，我们祝你一切顺利。
Guest DJing for our program today from Mr. Nick Spitzer, who's music show American Roots normally broadcasts out of New Orleans. He chose songs for us from his exile. Other musical help from Jessica Hopper. Special thanks today to so many people, Margie Rockland, Stephen Elliott, Alex Kotlowitz, Kristy Krueger, Lisa Moore, Richard Burkhurt, Harry Scheiber, Davy Rothbart, Eve Warmfeldt, Abram Himmelstein, Anya Borg, Justin Lundgering, Kirsta Kurtz Burke, Aaron Zimmerman, Anjali Rasperry, and Michelle [? Gibeaumot, ?] and really too many people to name, friends of the program, and strangers who emailed us with stories and suggestions this week, thank you to you all.
我们节目今天的客座DJ是尼克·斯皮策先生，他的音乐节目《美国根源》通常在新奥尔良播出。他为我们从流亡中选择了歌曲。其他音乐帮助来自杰西卡·霍珀。今天特别感谢这么多人，玛吉·罗克兰、斯蒂芬·埃利奥特、亚历克斯·科特洛维茨、克里斯蒂·克鲁格、丽莎·摩尔、理查德·伯克赫特、哈里·谢伯、戴维·罗斯巴特、伊夫·沃姆费尔特、阿布拉姆·希梅尔斯坦、安雅·博格、贾斯汀·隆德格林、科尔斯塔·库尔茨·伯克、亚伦·齐默尔曼、安贾莉·拉斯伯里和米歇尔·[？吉博莫，？]，还有太多人无法一一列举，感谢节目的朋友们，以及本周向我们发送故事和建议的陌生人，谢谢你们所有人。
You can download today's program and our archives at audible.com/thisamericanlife. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
你可以在 audible.com/thisamericanlife 下载今天的节目和我们的档案。《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资金支持鸣谢]
WBEZ management oversight for our program by Mr. Torey Malatia, who's had favorites here at the radio station who were not me.
WBEZ对我们节目的管理监督由托里·马拉蒂亚先生负责，他在广播电台有最爱，那个人不是我。
Just the cutest ding dang kids that would call me Auntie
就是那些会叫我“阿姨”的最可爱的孩子。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of this American life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周再见，会有更多美国生活的故事。
PRI, Public Radio International.
国际公共广播电台。